j'ai reproché à sylvie of dégâts dès que
loana a un problème d'informer un site
et contre les informations permanentes
immédiates qu'elles donnent à ce site
j'ai dit que selon des sources que
j'avais elle était rétribué pour donner
ces informations qu'elle touchait
d'argent en gros des clones à aller mal
et elle elle dit que vous l'avez
soudoyer pour avoir des infos sur
l'ohada aller de l'avant sylvie ortega
et la remercie elle va bien merci
seigneur tu es gamin cette embellie
merci mam était une musique mettais un
truc là les réformes on anniversaire
merci sylvie merci ce n'est pas un
poisson d'avril à septembre à bâle alors
après la leyre en tant que gilbert
d'elle déjà et il vous la souhaite c'est
bien là on shore soir alors s'ils virent
tega eux
merci d'être là gilles verdez vous
reprochent de donner des informations à
des journaux people
est ce que c'est vrai ou pas pourra voir
au large des informations sur le wan ce
que c'est vrai ou pas alors tout d'abord
on va répondre à monsieur gilles verdez
qui se trouve présent face de moi j'ai
envie de lui dire tout simplement que il
avant d'accuser il me dit moi cette
fille m'exaspère il est là avec ses
gestes en train de battre des ailes
tel un corbeau tenant dans son bec une
info qu'on ne ferait pas de mal et moi
ouais je parle de vous donc bien
évidemment de vous un
de vous ça c'est une certitude donc le
wave bien bon ok ça vous ressemble c'est
comme ça bon why not
par contre ce n'est pas crédible
l'ag répondre à vos questions puisque la
question était donc et la prochaine fois
vous éviterez quand même d'essayer de
m'insulter un blanc et de me rabaisser
parce que vous c'est trop facile de vous
rabaisser ton est ce que vous pouvez
répondre s'il veut c est le pauvre m
ouais je répondre alors sur ses temps
que la question était avec eux des
magazines me paie pour donner des
escargots va lancer régulièrement des
cas d'un problème elles ont pareillement
à payer si on a bien compris on appelle
t elle c'est bon tu ton et au corbeau
est bon voilà où donc non je n'étais
jamais été payé ous êtes bien placé pour
le savoir
on est d'abord à la première question il
est balancé moi je rigole pas là j'avoue
balancer des infos sur l'internet
vous dites je n'avais rien si je pars
large part alors vous balancer les
impôts dgi ylang-ylang sur ton sur ben
oui parce qu'alors alors si évident mais
la question c'est derrière la question
est ce qu'on va avancer les infos ça
m'est arrivé de tours voilà des infos
sur la rade et qu'elle va là non pas sur
l'eau un art il n'y a pas que loana dans
la vie ok d'accord et iata vous dans la
vie non plus ok vous avez balancé l'info
sur les infos sur loana noms d'élus si
je n'étais pas là le sujet était elle
est payée pour balancer
alors c'est non on est payé pour
balancer des infos brink aucune manche
je suis payé vous êtes bien placé pour
le savoir qu'on est pas payée pour bien
a lancé des infos et je fais en sorte de
donner très peu d'interviews et
m'exprimer sur mon compte et ajustements
afin qu'on ne dise pas que on me paye
pour des interwiew premier point
deuxième point la seule et unique fois
que j'ai le bandit du fric
est-ce que vous balancer des infos sur
loana dès qu'elle va mal vous n'avez pas
répondu j'ai dit oui puis non régulés
faites vous faites allusion oui au soir
ou en tous les soirs mais tous les soirs
nous ont arrêtés aux soirées pour
avocate a besoin quoiqu'il vers des
rires
et vous mais se dit clairement les
choses desclaux assemblée d'information
est informé par madame ortega way qui
sort fait de l'argent sur le dos des
doublons et ex temps et je les crues et
je m'excuse auprès des téléspectateurs
j'ai cru que vous étiez une personne
fiable digne de foi une source
journalisme en aurait réagi tuer vous
exploitez le mal pour vous ni vos torts
y est arrivé vous me laissez pas
m'exprimer montée madame ampère
magiquement pas recommencer vous vous
dites que je mens alors oui mais ça fait
deux heures six records dans la question
non je n'ai jamais été payée je demander
une fois c'était pour une interview qui
ne concernait pas loana
j'ai laissé tomber ses préférés de
tableau qui me concerne il faut cerner
autre chose que loana bref j'ai laissé
tomber je préférais m'exprimer maritime
s'installe d'accord avec public
oui avec public voilà au sénat voilà
d'autre part vous quant à vous vous avez
voulu soutirer des infos et oui ou à qui
j'ai su tirer désormais vous êtes malade
ou quoi agacer la vérité on arrêtait
paraissait m'énerver là combien de fois
à l'étagé hulot n'ait rien journée
qu'ils aient jamais payé son billet
crois pas les infos déjà n'y en a pas
ideo gâchis des os et le premier
rappelle aussi ce que vous appeler comme
ça ok et je trouve pas ça drôle pas se
déforme et qu'il faut respecter
voilà toutes les personnes et d'ailleurs
et la merguez et demande de criera
quelque chose
effectivement vous m'avait proposé de
l'argent un billet je sais pas d'où ils
sortiraient mais vous l'avez prouvé
qu'on n'aurait dépensé l'épreuve mais
vous êtes malade mais des preuves belle
époque bernard vous faisiez vous
souvenez de van loan art est ce que
c'est moi qui vous aide vous aider à une
fois le premier sur combien de france a
parlé au téléphone non j'admets pas que
vous remettez en cause mon mauvais côté
là non juste que je ne croyais pas que
vous remettiez on pose mon honnêteté
j'ai jamais à jouer avec ça je ne rigole
pas avec ça non
les repas si j'avais dû à lui voulu
bosser avec moi je suis désolé de vous
le roi avait subi le 2 mai 2002 minutes
c'est gilles verdez et sylvie bd on se
calme deux minutes les chéris moi je
vous le dis je n'y crois pas un instant
à ce que gilles verdez vous dites me
donnez vous a proposé de l'argent pour
avoir des enfants soldats
je sais qu'il vers des faits des
enquêtes et qu'il appelle dans tout
paris si proposé de l'argent à tout le
monde franchement vous salir mon nom je
dis pas tout en provocation mais s'il
veut peut-être une info non mais si je
voulais une info je vous appellerai pas
je vais ramener diop et on passe à la
dernière partie d'émission
merci vous le temps de se calmer gilles
verdez est ce que vous avez appelé
sylvie pour avoir des infos sur loana le
premier soir où loana à disjoncter il ya
quelques mois sylvie était dans l'appart
j'étais avec d'autres gens qui m'ont
passé sylvie dont s'énervait pas le
téléphone j'ai même pas votre téléphone
ils m'ont passé sylvie parti dans
l'appartement de loana donc là j'ai
parlé avec 6 lui je me souviens s'est
passé avec sylvie ça s'est très bien
passé elle était dans l'appartement
c'était l'époque où elle est encore
accessible et où elle parlait
normalement en respectant les gens
elle avait des informations et caetera
et donc s arrêtera les gens qui me
parlent mal après et qui disent comme ça
que je suis quelqu'un ya deux voies là
dessus ce pas comment mais il y avait
des témoins ce soir-là jeu
jamais volé l'argent sur la gamme et des
témoins ce qui vous aurait dit gilles
verdez ou ce que vous dites qu'il vous a
proposé dans gentit mois et la seule
fois où on s'est parlé de moi mais ça
c'est votre parole contre la mienne mais
vous jetez le glyphe aller à même de
jeter le bus s'est levé s'est levé la
banque on termine on peut vous croire
moi moi je m'en fous et non mais ça ça
marche pas c'est pas parce que tu sais
moi ccco gilles eboli d'accès des
sciences et vie qu'est-ce que vous
aurais dit gilles alors expliquez nous
mais voulait une info ce moment mais
intelligente de loana intelligible tout
simplement une info concernant l'hôpital
de loana était prêt allez vas-y contre
moi un petit billet parce que tout le
temps que j'ai eus loi n'a été à
l'hôpital pendant un mois où je m'étais
tous les jours entre un supporter les
courtes ailleurs personne à bouger son
cul et je redis encore un et ça veut
sauver loana est comme assure aline
avaient très bien dit les choses et on
sait on était ok de ce côté là quand je
suis arrivé la première fois le deuxième
plateau 1
c'était effectivement quelqu'un que pas
soigné on ne peut pas refuser
justement c'est là qu'on y arrive
vous avez voulu savoir tous ou et et
loana à l'hôpital tout le monde m'a
téléphoné j'ai gardé le secret jusqu'au
bout j'ai appelé autant papa a eu aucun
pas par hasard et on se connaît tous sa
on se connaît tous plus ou moins
d'accord ok j'ai appelé personne
j'ai fait mes courses mon sac et je suis
partisan mais juste et il vous en prie
j'avais pu prendre du fric vous en
souvenez vous de l'argent
il a proposé la reprise moi je vous ai
proposé par beau temps mais je fais
malade j'étais entre jussieu elle est
malade non mais cyril mois moi je
n'aurais je pas calmé je m'énervais 2
c'est la probité
elle remet encore probité journalistique
non mais les gars je vous ai proposé de
l'argent pour une offre proposée mais de
quel droit une commande cette maladie
à 37,2 tout va bien c'est honteux de
dire ça c'est honteux la vj levée mais
madame l'accord aux pinces et vous
l'accordé vous s'il vous plaît vous
savez quoi
il n'en n'a comme moi ça dérange vous
savez pour que vous me dérangeait pas du
tout mais si je dérange pas du tout les
deux mois joue pas ça du tout un mythe
bon alors je sais le billet vous avez
des nouvelles de joindre à ces noms
pourquoi aurais-je terminé fini de toute
façon loana que ce soit ni qu'aux autres
donc soumeillan les nouvelles
c'est très compliqué ben c'est
effectivement quelqu'un qu'on ne peut
pas soigner et qui vous plante des
couteaux dans le dos on voit bien quand
même que elle sait ce qu'elle fait 1
elle n'est pas tout à fait voilà
maintenant bon on avait peu de nouvelles
vous ne voulez plus en avoir bas où j'en
ai ouais j'en ai parce qu'on a tous
quand même mais bon
terminé voilà à quoi on peut pas sauver
le monde en même temps merci sylvie en
demande un franc je suis franche
maintenant c'est d'avoir un abri crois
pas c'est le chichon tu crois pas du
tout je connais gilbert des depuis des
années françois vie alors je sais pas
peut-être que vous avez mal interprété
un truc qui vous a dit mais je ne crois
pas du tout et que j'avais super 10s
vous aideront à tirer avant la retirer
retirer ce que vous avez dit retient la
vérité non mais vous mettez en cause mon
honnêteté mais c'est dégueulasse mais
c'est dégueulasse vous mettez la mienne
ah mais oui parce que vous avez à oui
mais voilà c'est ça c'est ce à quoi
déborder des informations sur loana
madame je vendais des informations sur
l'honneur vous inviter pour ça le dîner
de cons merci cette partie de mon con
merci syfy en tout cas merci et gilles
verdez j'y crois pas du tout vous
inquiétez pas fini alors si si l'on
valide le croit
merci sylvie en tout cas arrétez arrétez
arrétez arrétez m'énerve alors que c'est
très calme arrêté
[Rires]
c'est un vrai talent et silvio a passé
un autre sujet n'intéresse pas cette
semaine qu'a décidé d'être franche et
extra chambert vous voilà et bim
ça fait mal la vérité de cov mallet ça